since I was a child I've always loved a
good story stories of us become the
people we dreamed of being
lies the told a deeper truth I always
thought that could de some small part in
that grand tradition
and for my pains I got this my new
narrative
hey guys Pete here this will be my
Westworld season 1 episode 10 the season
finale trailer breakdown and predictions
about what we're gonna see there will be
spoilers for everything that's happened
in the show up to this point so if
you're not caught up please stop
watching now so this trailer like all
the west-world trailers is jam-packed
with little flashes and different things
so we can't exactly see all of what's
going on because this one threw him got
all the screen grabs and before we look
at them individually let's talk about
what Ford actually says in the narration
he says since I was a child I've always
loved a good story stories help us
become the people we dreamed of being
lies that told a deeper truth I always
thought I could play some small part in
that grand tradition and for my pains I
got this my new narrative I think it's a
safe bet to assume that this is Ford
presenting the narrative just like we
saw Lea Sizemore do back in the
beginning of the season so let's break
the trailer down see what all the images
look like and then at the end we'll get
into the fun part which is the
speculation the speculation of what's
actually gonna happen in the season
finale I have to note that I'm really
excited about this but kind of
disappointed at the same time that it's
already here the trains headed to town
and Teddy's on it he's fresh off being
killed by Angela at the end of the last
episode and while I'm not exactly sure
why it was necessary to kill him for him
to come back we do see later in the
trailer that he's changed his narrative
quite a bit felix is with Maeve who's in
modern-day street clothes rather than
her normal getup which she normally
wears while inside the park they're on
an elevator which means we can't exactly
tell if they're going up or down or
where they're headed at the moment but
we definitely get a better idea as the
trailer moves on Dolores is in the
cemetery that we've seen through her
dreams or visions in the past she has
the men in black in tow in this version
of the scene and there's no way to tell
actually what's happening we get an
interesting bit right here though if you
look closely at this grave marker it
actually says Dolores Abernathy on it so
she's been having thoughts about this
place and we even saw her bent down in
front of the grave but at least as far
as my knowledge goes no
never realize that I was her own grave
there's a shot of Ford in his office
then we see what I think is William
riding a horse up a hill and then we see
him standing on top looking out on what
I imagine is Sweetwater then as
mentioned Teddy shoots the guy who bumps
him when he comes off the train now this
is a part we've seen in his normal
narrative loop at least two if not three
times and each time he just walks by
this time he turns around and shoots
which is a clear deviation from his
normal narrative loop Flores has a
shocked or painful look on her face and
this looks like it takes place in the
cemetery because it looks like there's a
none of those grave markers in the
background in cold storage Clementine is
still in the same room where she had the
gun held on Ford and her old friend
Maeve comes to visit her where she's at
you tell by the look on mames face that
she's really sad to see her in this
state but I also think there's more to
this than just her coming to say goodbye
to Clementine he's obviously not
responsive anymore there's probably a
good reason that they're in cold storage
and we'll get to that later there's an
exchange of books between the Loras and
the man in black if we had to read the
expressions she looks like she gets
angry about whatever he says and then he
looks shocked at whatever response that
she gives him we have a shot of Ford the
coincides with the end of the words that
he says in the narration and to me it
looks like that's the top of the lorises
head there's no real way to tell for
sure but that seems like the best guess
then we break into these quick flashes
the first one the man in black is
grabbed and being pulled across the room
that's inside the church as far as I can
tell and I feel like that's definitely
Dolores that's pulling him the look on
his face is priceless and I really want
to see where this particular thing is
headed there's a shot of William where a
Confederate or charges him and he shoots
him it's kind of about a sequence but we
see this in another one in a second we
see Hector he grabs the attack that we
met earlier that that Elsie blackmailed
to get in to see the stray and there's
this picture of the command center with
someone standing on the left hand side
but I can't really make out who it is
the figures clearly you know important
in the frame but whenever i zoom in on
it
lighten it up and everything else you
can't make out from the face who it
actually is it could be Bernard but
Bernard is you know dead since the last
episode so it's definitely not
confirmable in one way or the other as
far as I'm concerned let me know what
you guys think or if you you know if
you're better at Photoshop and you
looked at it and you can actually see
Logan is reclining on a pile of bodies
and here we see that it looks like
Williams using one of the hosts to
execute the other host by shooting in
the back of the head there's another
picture of William but if you look
closely at this one it looks like he's
actually in the city the guy behind him
he looks like he's wearing like you know
everyday clothes not a uniform there's a
shot of the disguise may have moving
through the center with Felix and Hector
who were both dressed as Tex and one of
a security officer in the cold storage
area with a rifle this image popped up
before and we assumed it was Stubbs but
it's clearly not Stubbs if you look at
this picture Ford is wearing his banquet
gear I guess he's got a you know like a
tuxedo on and he's overlooking Teddy and
Delores as best I can tell I mean it's
definitely Teddy and I don't know who
also be laying there besides Delores
this links back to his speech and the
presentation of his new narrative I'm
sure so we can see that Teddy and
Delores are main characters
there's a quick flash of Armistice
attacking her tech and then we see Mae
makes it at least to the escalator that
takes you down to the train platform at
this point she's walking by herself and
she looks like a regular person but
there's no telling what happens when she
hits that escalator there's another shot
of the Loras holding the gun to her head
and then it fades to black to where we
hear Bernards voice say these violent
delights have violent ends one thing I
want to mention before I forget Evan
Rachel Wood tweeted during the episode
or after the episode yesterday saying
that the finale is 90 minutes long so
that's pretty awesome to know I don't
know about you guys but the big question
on my mind is what's up with Maeve what
I mean by that is we see her getting
close to the edge of getting out of the
park but it's obviously a little bit
confusing as to what if anything Ford
knows about this I guess we could look
at it like there's three possibilities
one he doesn't know Bernard was shocked
when he saw that someone had messed with
her settings
that doesn't mean that Ford doesn't know
plus if we remember Sylvester in Felix
when they were actually changing those
things they said that someone else had
already been messing with her someone
with much higher security clearance
there's a chance that was Elsie whenever
she changed things but it could also be
dr. Ford of course which brings us to
our second possibility Ford's been
behind the whole thing the whole time
there's a chain of events that led to
this and he could be involved with it
right from the beginning
I mean his introducing the reveries is
where it started I guess the question
there would be that he'd do that on
purpose so this would happen and the
third possibility is that he's not
behind it but he does know what's going
on and he's basically letting it happen
because he sees a way that he can use it
to his advantage call them possibilities
because they're all literally possible
and you can make a good argument for any
one of them being the case since we
don't have any concrete proof one way or
the other
from the looks of these shots of Maeve
and what we've seen her be capable of to
get to this point it leads you to
believe that she was gonna make it out
of the park at the same time however
that photo with her going down the
escalator it really looks like it's kind
of one of those is a setup for one of
those really heartbreaking endings where
she only has a few yards to go and
doesn't make it inside the Train I'm a
little on the fence about her and
Bernard and Bernard and Ford in the last
episode to let me know what you guys
think about this do you think her
sending Bernard off after their
interaction was just a big ploy to keep
dr. Ford preoccupied while she put her
plan into motion at least what we see
here seems to be the case you know we
see armistice attacking that's gonna
cause commotion we see her and her cold
storage which there she has a whole
bunch of Kaos agents that she could send
in different directions I think the main
goal of that whole deal is to just cause
disruption like I said I don't see how
she would have them like aid her in some
other way we get a glimpse of what Ford
was up to with his narrative and I think
it's safe to say that Teddy is the main
character I know a lot of people think
Wyatt is gonna be Teddy and this could
be true but this is another thing we
need to talk about a little bit more in
the comments toward head Angela kill him
so he would come back to the center and
be under repair she mentioned to him
specifically that he wasn't
but maybe in the next life he also had
the revised memory where he realizes
that why it didn't make him kill those
people that he was actually just running
around shooting us so is this what that
narrative is actually about him becoming
Wyatt I don't know honestly it's not
clear there are definitely why it's men
running around in the park Angela was
there to meet the man in black and send
Teddy back into the center I don't want
to ramble on about this because there's
a lot to think about and it does look
like we'll find out for sure whenever
Ford releases the new narrative so what
do we think is gonna happen I think that
we will definitely get a conclusion to
Maeve's current story and also to
William and whether he's the man in
black for sure or not I think that this
has been set up - those are the two big
reveals that we can guarantee and while
we might not actually understand the
true nature of Arnold and Ford's
relationship at the end we should have a
better idea of how this whole thing
started at the beginning of the season
with 90 minutes to go I hope that we get
a lot of things clarified because one
thing I noticed that you know on
rewatching is that they are actually
putting things together pretty tightly
it's not like we get this constant
succession of new things to speculate
about without ever getting answers it
seems like they are putting answers in
place as far as the big character loose
ends we don't get any hints in the end
the trailer at all no shots of LCU no
shots of stubs and no the shots of
Bernard although we do hear his voice at
the end we also don't get any real
indication about what the corporation is
doing but I feel pretty certain that
everything Ford's doing is an effort to
stop them from being able to take
control and force them out I do feel
like there'll be some conclusion to that
before this is all said and done only I
don't have a good idea of what it is
other than I have a feeling that Ford's
probably going to win there's still a
lot of speculative theories out there
that people are holding on to I guess
the biggest one is that for it's
actually a host I don't really see it I
don't think the last episode moved us
anywhere closer to it and the trailer
definitely doesn't show anything that
makes me change my mind the other big
one that people have been floating ever
since Arnold was first introduced is
that Arnold is actually somewhere still
in the park at the center of the maze
perhaps or something like that I've
never really been sure about this I kind
of doubt
and again nothing in the trailer made me
feel like that they're saying hey you're
gonna find out oh and there's the idea
that Logan's gonna die Williams gonna
kill him or that actually Logan's the
man in black instead of William I think
that idea that Logan's the man in black
is because people consider their
personality used to be closer matched
but I'm from the thought process that
the man in black is not a psychopath or
sociopath he's just playing a game and
as far as what we saw in the last
episode that points way more towards
William who says he learned how to play
the game and basically experienced the
rebirth that the man in black told us
about several episodes ago do I think
he's gonna kill him I mean that could
happen Logan doesn't seem to be an
important character moving forward and
that would be a good backstory for why
you know the man in blacks wife killed
herself and all those things I'm just
not 100% sold on it I mean it's been out
there forever and I just don't see that
there's compelling evidence that he has
to die it's something that could happen
but you know it's just not the most
crucial part of the story I don't think
last video got a lot of comments about
LC or Stubbs or both being replaced by
hosts down the road this is definitely
possible it would help to explain why
they don't really give us the the clear
answer about LC and also the Stubbs
thing actually makes a lot of sense in
that he was captured in that sector
after being lured there by you know the
signal that's something that he could
easily set up and something that he
could use in the future a security guard
that was you know Barnard status that
does whatever he says without question I
was kind of thinking that Stubbs was a
host in the first place so you know that
kind of just threw me off a little bit
when I watched the last episode so we're
all right let me know what you guys
think in the comments let's talk about
this let's figure it out please like the
video if you enjoyed it and please
subscribe to my channel so you'll be
notified of all the new videos I put out
thanks for watching I'll talk to you
soon